I honestly didn't even process the
reality of my situation because the more
I thought about it like the sadder more
hopeless I would feel and so I focused
on the few things that were under my
control which is like I can do these
things when I talk about advertising I
want to talk about selling I talk about
those things boiled down to the actual
actions because I had to think of it in
that way because it was the only way
that it wasn't overwhelming it's like I
just have to make a hundred reach outs
or I just have to spend 100 a day and I
have to look at the uh turn off the ones
that are bad and do more of the stuff
that starts to work that was the process
of getting me from kind of like dark uh
to a better outcome that single skill of
being able to generate leads independent
of the industry has been like my get out
of jail free card